ville wardha on the northern outskirts
of Brussels was once known as a breeding
ground for jihadists many young Muslims
living here felt ostracized from Belgian
society even today there's still a lot
of mistrust one of them tries to
discourage the others from talking to
reporters all they're going to do is
make us look bad he says but then a few
open up they say they feel stigmatized
because so many young people went from
valve or de to fight in Syria they were
recruited by the so-called Islamic state
same on my sample is like it's bad I
don't like thinking about it cuz
sometimes it's people you know and they
come back dead well he's okay I [ __ ] off
I'm against these guys going to Syria
that's my opinion she will appeal so is
she on the pink modell boo dirty nose
almost all the young men who went to
Syria he did not fall prey to the
recruiters his Muslim parents always
taught him that war is not wholly Ali
participe these guys really thought they
have to take part in the fighting for
them jihad is an ideal and they want to
follow that ideally the Imams in
Belgium's mosques have lost their
influence over many young people in the
suburbs so they offer help on social
media in an attempt to stop young people
from being lured by hate propaganda the
professor de menthe what was it ever
disappear we're using social media to
try to make a difference our Quran
teachers call on their students to
engage with radicalized young people on
Facebook students use arguments to
explain to them that Islam is a religion
of respect and love monkey mcd's anoka
who universe pay the more the jihadist
recruiters typically reach out to
disaffected young people promising them
a path to heroism
a website called Sharia for Belgium used
to tell young Muslims that they would
one day lead an Islamic Republic in
Belgium the website is now banned its
leaders have been convicted of terrorist
activities Dmitry bunting was one of the
plaintiffs in a lawsuit filed against
the organization his son Ian believed
the propaganda of the extremists and
went to Syria bond t'ink risked his own
life to bring his son back he says the
Belgian State left him in the lurch of
course we asked to help by the
authorities by the police by youth
organizations and the answer was they
couldn't do something because there was
a freedom of organization there was
freedom of speech there was freedom of
religion you know they were laughing
with me they took me as a clown you know
what they said to me that is not even my
business to know where is my son as
excuse me I'm a father the Belgian state
has been roundly criticized for years
the politics of division have fractured
the country according to one expert
that's the reason Belgium finds it
harder than most other European
countries to integrate immigrants and
their descendants yep I got its own
reward in the last 20 years Belgium has
not systematically fought against
radical Islam and now it's become a huge
problem that's also due to Belgium's
lack of unity Islamists have taken
advantage of the lack of coordination
between the Flemish and walloon
communities absolute Gandhi National 20
community Belgium raised its security
threat to the highest level after
Tuesday's attacks but the mayor of
Eduardo says increased security isn't
enough society has to reach out to those
at risk of radicalization before
predisposed position new for we need
more facilities for young people in new
schools especially here in blue border
we also need more sports facilities so
she necessarily others I think sports
are a great way of promoting integration
so Fosse par les paul
the mayor of valve order is credited
with improving conditions in his
municipality but he says it's important
to remain vigilant and keep reaching out
to those most vulnerable to jihadist
recruiters